[Music]
you're looking Wow
I'm so happy to be here I'm
house-sitting for my sister right now
and I wanted to share with you I just
learned the craziest thing about
house-sitting did you guys know that
when you are house-sitting you are not
supposed to break their stuff super
weird right when she gets back from out
of town it's gonna be like one of those
games in highlights magazine cuz I'm
just gonna be like okay you remember
what your apartment looked like before
can you spot the six differences I broke
five plates and one of the cats is gone
I'm just gonna tell you last time I was
house-sitting for her I did something
that I know for sure you're not supposed
to do when you're house-sitting which is
I made a sex tape in the apartment
hear me out I'm not in it
it's not what you think I just made a
tape of one of her cats just going at it
with one of her winter boots I didn't
even have to direct him he was just
doing it every night for a half hour
while maintaining eye contact with me
I'll tell you what I find most
disturbing about that aside from the
fact that I am an adult and I filmed it
is that she also has a girl cat right
he's got options how ugly must that girl
cat feel that every night he's like
listen I know that you are literally the
only other cat I've ever seen still
think I'm going with the boo yeah and I
know this isn't appropriate for me to
say as a human but her girl cat is a 10
okay her boy cat may be a 4 they're a
classic la couple it really should work
I love living in LA my favorite radio
station here is Kade a you guys like
Kade a yeah it's awesome they play a lot
of 90s hip-hop which I love my only
problem with it is I am a woman and
sometimes they talk about us like we
can't hear them but I don't want to stop
listening so instead I've just been
pretending that the songs are about
something completely different
I'm just like willfully misconstruing
the lyrics like when juveniles like girl
you look good why don't you back that
thing up I'm like he's probably talking
about her hard drive right
she should back that up she's got a lot
of important work files on there
he doesn't want her to lose them because
he cares about her career that's not
juvenile at all that's very mature when
snoops like [ __ ] ain't [ __ ] I'm like
you're right they're not they're
valuable members of society gonna take
that double negative turn it into a
double positive thank you very much I
got hoes in different area codes my
gardening business is taking off we're
expanding multiple counties I I'm single
at this point in my set that's not
supposed to be a twist
I'm not Shama lotting you there have
been clues I love being single the only
thing I don't like about it is people
say really weird stuff to you when
you're single for a long time at least
if you're a woman I think if you're a
man they just talk to you like you're a
person but when you're a woman people
say really weird stuff they say stuff
like aren't you afraid
[Applause]
like aren't you afraid of dying alone
which is jumping ahead a few years I
think but I answer honestly I say yes I
am afraid of dying alone because I fear
death no matter the circumstance I'm
afraid of dying alone I'm also afraid of
dying in a gangbang it's not the alone
part that's freaking me out about that
at least if I die alone I'm not ruining
a party I want that to be my legacy
besides you guys I'm not gonna die alone
there are going to be so many cats there
thank you so much for your time I member
I know thank you